this is bubble she is a long-tailed  chinchilla and she is beyond cute bubble  is a female long tail chinchilla an  endangered rodent native to the Andes  mountain range in South America  chinchillas are tough to spot in the  wild they live approximately 4,000  meters above sea level and they're  nocturnal emerging only at night to  munch on grasses and herbes they  navigate their rocky terrain with the  help of claws on the backs of their feet  this makes them expert rock climbers  chinchillas are adored for their hair  bubbles exquisite Kurt is long silky and  soft each follicle can contain 60 hairs  it is so thick that it naturally resists  parasites but unfortunately since the  16th century  chinchillas have been coveted in the fur  trade hunting chinchillas today is  illegal but still persists which is why  they're endangered in the wild this is  the long-tailed chinchilla  [Music]  you